ELIZABETH CHOE: So I think the
idea of a workshop-based class,
a hands-on class, that's what's
becoming trendy in education.
At least at MIT right now.
It's bringing it back
to mind and hand.
They won't work
if students don't
bring anything to workshop
or have anything ready.
So that's why the first
two or three days of class
were very, very information
intense to bring them up
to the point where they had a
script that they could actually
read aloud at the table read.
Or that they would have a
scene they could storyboard.
How was it leading
the workshops?
Because I could kind of let
you guys take over for those.
JOSHUA GUNN: Yeah, I mean
I think it was great.
I mean, I think we
couldn't have done
what we did if they
hadn't come to the class
with a portion of a script
that they could storyboard.
Or do some sort of
storyboard work on.
I think maybe in the future
you might think about having--
well, I don't have.
Setting it up so that
there's instruction
about say, storyboarding, and
examples and kind of models.
Then have them do that
and then have them return
for the critique.
As opposed to trying to compress
all of that into one class.
But again, that
requires more time.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: My only
workshop-- workshops
are great because it means that
you rely a lot more on stuff
that you sort of just know and
can talk off the cuff about
and don't have to prepare long
lectures, which is fantastic.
ELIZABETH CHOE:
But that requires
that you actually are just
natively an expert in that.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: But the
nice thing about that
is that you can reduce the
time you spend speaking
and increase the time that they
spend working and speaking.
And I think the earlier that
you get the students talking
and doing things
things in the workshop,
the more quickly they realize
that it's not a lecture.
And that they're not going
to sit there and absorb.
That they have to
actually do something.
ELIZABETH CHOE: So you had
people reading their scripts
from the beginning
of your workshop.
There was no easing into it.
It was pretty much just
like all right, this
is the script that so and
so submitted last night
OK, come up and read it for us.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Yeah.
And then they get over their
nerves and they just do it.
And then you roll into it.
The hard thing about doing
that is-- giving feedback
in a workshop is tough
because you can't just
be like great job.
Go sit down.
That was great that you
did it, but we're not
going to give you any
constructive criticism.
You've got to say OK, here's
what I would do differently.
But you have to do
it in such a way
that it's not ego destroying.
And that applies for
any of the stuff.
It's hard to do,
especially for hosting,
because there you're commenting
on their tone of voice,
their delivery style--
ELIZABETH CHOE: Their existence.
GEORGE ZAIDAN:
The way they talk.
You know?
So it's a tricky thing to get.
You sort of err on the side
of being a little bit softer
than you probably would be.
JOSHUA GUNN: It's also-- sorry.
It's also interesting
to get them--
I think just from my basic
pedagogical experience,
because I did teach creative
writing for a while.
It's nice to get
them-- to get students,
as you said, doing peer work
where they're critiquing
each other so there isn't just
this authority figure that
has all the answers.
There's also this innate sense
that we all have, and students
have, of what's
working and what's not.
Because they are
audience members too
and they have that
audience sensibility.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Actually a
really important thing was
to establish that the medium
in which we are working had no
established best practices, and
that was something that I tried
to emphasize a lot
and say, you know,
I have very strong opinions on
what I think is good hosting
and what isn't.
But at the end of
the day, you do
what you want as long as
you can justify it to me.
You can take or leave
my advice on how
I think you should
edit this section,
but if you want to stick
with what you have and you're
able to write out why--
JOSHUA GUNN: You're
going to get an F.
ELIZABETH CHOE: But
an A for effort.
That's fine as long as I
see that they're consciously
processing their
own personal taste.
What was the thing
you just said?
GEORGE ZAIDAN: I'm
saying that you
don't want to just be the
only person critiquing, which
is really important.
CHRIS BOEBEL: It's
really, really important
and I think one of
the things about
that too is trying to
make the classroom I
guess kind of a safe space where
people can be really honest.
And it's like, you know what?
Someone is probably going
to go at you and your work
at some point, but you
need to be OK with that.
And if you feel that you need
to be honest with somebody
about their work, that's OK too.
As long as you're not
doing it on some kind
of illegitimate grounds.
If it's a legitimate
critique, you
should feel OK about saying it.
JOSHUA GUNN: Yeah,
that's a good point.
I think too, it can sometimes
be helpful to just kind of lay
the ground rules of critique.
Like what's personal.
I mean, sometimes it's
not obvious to students
what's a personal attack.
What's constructive
criticism of the work.
CHRIS BOEBEL:
Sometimes people need
instruction on peer review.
JOSHUA GUNN: Yeah, exactly.
You can't expect that
people know the rules.
ELIZABETH CHOE:
Luckily, just having
Jamie at every single
class was really helpful.
I mean, it's hard.
In an ideal world,
every class would
have a staff of
five people who are
all experts on different
facets of the industry.
And then a dedicated
instructional designer
facilitating group
discussions every day.
JOSHUA GUNN: Two
instructors per student.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Let's
recommend that.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Right.
But you know, that's
what it takes.
It really does.
Because if Jamie
wasn't there, I don't
know how to facilitate
classroom discussion.
She would be able to
interject and sort of coach
these things subliminally
without having
to establish guys, these
are the classroom rules.
No picking on people.
It was just all done
very organically.
And that's actually very hard.
This is such a cop-out
answer to be like,
it's important to foster
a good classroom space.
Go do it.
You know?
But I don't really know how to
give actionable items to people
who are trying to do
this in their schools.
I think one thing
I tried to do was,
and this was off of
Jamie's suggestion,
was to do every single
assignment that I assigned
to the students.
So on day one when they had
to record a selfie pitch,
I did it and I was like
this is not perfect.
And the next day I
pointed out things
that I didn't like about it
or things that could have
been better about my own work.
So I think having
something physical
to be able to critique,
to sort of show people
how to critique it, you know?
It's not even just show
people what's wrong,
but show people the active
critiquing is really important.
Because if you don't have
the physical examples,
it's just like saying
lighting has to be done well.
Well, if you don't show them
an example of a well-lit scene,
they're not going
to be able to do it.
CHRIS BOEBEL: The things
you get from students
who aren't used to giving
that kind of critique
tend to be either oh, it was
good or I didn't like it.
And neither one of those
is particularly helpful.
JOSHUA GUNN: Yeah, or
in creative writing
class students will be
like, this is really deep.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yeah.
But then to be able to be there
as an instructor and say, OK.
Why do you think that?
CHRIS BOEBEL: Yeah, exactly.
Why is it good?
Why is it deep?
Why didn't you like it?
ELIZABETH CHOE:
Questions that drive them
to give a more tangible answer.
That's really important
in the live discussion.
And it's important, I think,
to have it in real time.
Which is why I
don't know how you
can scale this experience up.
If you offer this
as an online class,
for instance, I guess you
could have forums where
students critique each other.
But again, without the guidance
of someone who's practiced it.
That limits you.
And then someone
who responds like,
why do you think this was deep?
The next day, you sort
of lose that momentum.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: I mean,
the really great thing
is when this sort of
stuff happens on set.
Like when we were shooting the
episode about the exploding
wire and our student
host got to see you,
me, and the director
of photography
get into a fight about why we
thought the framing was wrong.
And I mean, it was
literally like,
what do you think
of this framing?
I hate it.
Why?
Because it looks like an
episode of Home Improvement?
Like an actual episode
of Home Improvement
or the show that they were
parodying in Home Improvement?
No, the crappy version.
OK.
Well, let's figure
out how to fix it.
Like that's the kind of
discussion that happens on set.
ELIZABETH CHOE: And that is so
much more helpful for someone
to see than sometimes people
struggle with framing.
Here are some tips.
Try to put the people
in this framing.
It might be more engaging.
That's sort of how media
things are presented right now.
But to see like
George and me fight,
is one, way more entertaining.
JOSHUA GUNN: I'm sure it is.
ELIZABETH CHOE: But two, I
think like she probably took
a lot more out of that than
watching a lecture series.